welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Star Wars the rises Skywalker
completed the Skywalker saga with an
overall fan pleasing grace note but
because it's Star Wars and no one hates
Star Wars more than people who preface
tweets and reviews with how they're
actually fans of their ironically
singular Star War the movie was not
without its detractors and one of them
it turns out is the director himself JJ
Abrams who when asked about the negative
reactions to the film had a surprising
answer well to be fair Abrams
immediately followed this by saying that
the people who love the movie are also
right and some deeper remarks about
online outraged culture and I find his
attempts to find nuance in this tribal
debate outrageous some observers have
interpreted the candid demeanor of
Abrams and certain cast members while
promoting this film as if you guys have
the opportunity to continue your
character stories on a Disney Plus
series would you take it nope some are
even going as far to say this perceived
saltiness is masking a deeper conspiracy
that the rise of Skywalker that we saw
was not JJ Abrams intended vision but
actually the result of studio
interference by the evil Disney
overlords look I don't know if I believe
it I don't feel that great about
offering legitimacy to online Crusaders
grasping at anonymous unverified claims
to justify their cynicism but as someone
who often does the same to justify my
hope I thought I would present to you
this mythical JJ Abrams cut of the rise
of Skywalker rejected story concepts
deleted footage both things we know were
changed and things we suspect were
changed not just because it might be
true but because I love how the sausage
gets made and reading these rumors makes
me appreciate the sausage we got even
more okay
perhaps the oddest discrepancy about the
rise of Skywalker is that back in August
2018 Doctor Who actor Matt Smith was
reported by Variety to have been cast in
a key role months later in March 2019
Smith told the LA Times as far as I
could tell I'm definitely not in the
movie as opposed he can tell could be
some of that dried British star Kasim
ork be that the matter was something
determinable to a degree as if he was
part of it at some point but then cut so
when the movie came out Matt Smith
complete absence from the film mixed
varieties report pretty weird yes places
like variety The Hollywood Reporter
deadline they aren't exactly winning
Pulitzer for their journalistic
integrity their sources are usually
fairly legit one unverified claim on
reddit by user you Lucasfilm Insider
okay so just that Smith could have been
cast as the son of mortis from these
Star Wars the Clone Wars animated series
son of mortis is a cosmic being he's
connected to the dagger of mortis he's
kind of part of the Star Wars is
equivalent to the Holy Trinity the
Father the Son the daughter and this
rumor says that Matt Smith as the son of
mortis would have been an antagonist in
the rise of Skywalker these are claims
that JJ Abrams developed this idea from
meetings with George Lucas but that
Disney shot it down because they worried
in general audiences wouldn't appreciate
deep cuts from the animated series and
that the relatively throwaway MacGuffin
of the stagger in the film was the last
remaining trace of this dagger of mortis
plots but they went up post with the
biggest claims came from user ego shop
who cited a secondary anonymous source
who claimed insider knowledge of the
rise of Skywalker's production and a
rumored director's cut this cut
according to the source was three hours
and two minutes long that's 40 minutes
longer than the theatrical cut so long
that JJ they say suggested it to be
turned into two tones at one point this
cut would have opened with Rey's
training and also a deleted scene
involving Rose there also would have
been the shot of the two resistance
woman at the end of the movie you kissed
holding hands here there was also a
longer version of the scene of kylo and
the burning forests of Mustafar losing
focus briefly as they heard Vader's
breathing now according to co-writer
Chris Terrio the return of Palpatine was
part of the story long before he and JJ
came on board apparently it came from
Lucasfilm president Kathleen Kennedy
herself to one it awaits unite all nine
films including the prequels under the
same antagonist though original director
Colin Trevorrow in the interview in
November 2019
credited Palpatine's returned to Abrams
so there's no confusion where this came
from but it has been part of the rise of
Skywalker story for several years that
Lightspeed skipping was also going to
clewd stops at the wookie planet
Kashyyyk Naboo and Kamino Jana was going
to be confirmed as Lando's daughter as
the film's visual dictionary has very
strongly hinted apparently this JJ cut
would have made it clearer what exactly
happened at the end of the duel on the
ruins of the second death star when Leia
connected with kylo and Rey healed
that through either dialogue visuals we
would have known for sure that ray
killed the kylo Ren identity and Leia
used her son's memory of his father to
resurrect his Ben solo identity Finn's
big secret that he wanted to tell ray
his force sensitivity would have been
explicitly stated and the moment bb-8
Hotwire's that hatch on the Star
Destroyer would have been actually thin
using the force to open it the moment
Rey heard the Jedi voices was actually
going to feature live-action cameos by
Hayden Christensen Ewan McGregor in
samuel l.jackson in costume surrounding
Rey as force ghosts protecting her from
the city
and lastly Ben solo was always going to
die in this story but his death scene
was apparently longer with more dialogue
and that big kiss was an addition by
Disney that JJ wasn't in support of okay
so fueling the enthusiasm of the release
to JJ cut campaign either intentionally
or unwittingly was dr. Dominic Monaghan
who confirmed the existence of a
director's cut and deleted scenes like
one with conics injuring her legs us.the
later shot of her limping but monoghan
wasn't necessarily referring to the
reddit description we've been talking
about Logan sorry if I'm bumming you out
with my skepticism over these reddit
claims they just sound like they're
coming from someone who doesn't know how
movies are made I'm not saying that as
some Disney loyalists I'm seeing that as
someone with a decade of experience
working on professional film and TV sets
as we speak right now I'm surrounded by
people working in the film and TV
industry
I'm not some anonymous redditor who
claims to have insider knowledge but
doesn't have the balls to use my name or
face this whole idea of Jedi ghosts
being live-action cameos sounds insane
from a production standpoint to me that
secrets only seemed possible because
they were simple vocal recordings
live-action cameos would work wire the
crew to fly in a half dozen high-profile
actors some of whom are famously
reluctant to appear in another Star Wars
film already bring them into a
soundstage put them through makeup in
costume which takes forever and then
later in post-production CGI them into
ghosts and somehow keep all of this a
secret this sequence was clearly
designed it to be audio JJ's sampled the
same Alec Guinness audio fragment that
he used in a nightmare back in the force
awakens it was a callback completing the
sentence JJ stardate an episode 7 voices
then voices now and that whole Matt
Smith's son of mortis rumor convenient
ignores Disney's total willingness to
confirm malls resurrection from the
Clone Wars in solo and their willingness
to include as the final shot of the
Mandalorians season spoiler warning for
the Mandalorian the freaking dark saber
so I feel like if JJ wanted the dagger
of mortis he would have gotten it now
sure of course there were reshoots and
edits made on this film it happens on
every movie like definitely some Rose
scenes were cut along with a number of
other things that were for pacing
reasons that not again was probably
referring to and I'll agree the first
time that this film did come off as
super rushed and clearly some moments
were trimmed out but probably our
alterations did we need fins for
sensitivity and Ben's Redemption and
Jana's origin to be explicitly stated
via dialogue that really have fixed
everything the haters didn't like about
the movie I don't know which of these JJ
Putz claims do you think are true
comment down below and hey let's keep it
Sol ok follow me on instagram or twitter
at a box and subscribe to new rock
starts with breakdowns of everything you
love thank you for joining me and yes I
just made this video to piss off the
Snider cut boys you've seen it and it
sucks
[Music]